"Fantástico, ya era hora. ¿Cuándo estará lista?
(Risas)
Los hombres tienen dos reacciones diferentes.
O les encanta la idea
o me miran medio resabiados
tratando de entender exactamente qué estoy tramando para sus testículos.
(Risas)
¿Pero por qué el mundo necesita una píldora masculina?
Bueno, ¿y si les dijera
que de los seis millones de embarazos por año en EE.UU.
tres millones son no deseados?
La mitad.
Es un número sorprendente.
Esos tres millones de embarazos no deseados
resultan en la gran mayoría de los más de un millón de abortos
realizados cada año en EE.UU.
Afortunadamente, el índice de embarazos no deseadas descendió en los últimos años
en torno al 10 %.
Esto se debe a que más mujeres usan métodos anticonceptivos
eficaces, reversibles y de efecto duradero.
Pero todavía necesitamos mejorar mucho.
Un enfoque que finalmente se está convirtiendo en una posibilidad tangible
son los mejores métodos anticonceptivos para hombres.
Piénsenlo.
Tenemos más de diez métodos anticonceptivos para mujeres:
píldoras, adhesivos, DIU, inyecciones, esponjas, anillos, etc.
Para los hombres, tenemos las mismas dos opciones
desde hace más de 100 años:
el condón y la vasectomía.
A pesar de que solo tenemos dos opciones,
ambas tienen notorios inconvenientes,
los hombres totalizan el 30 % del uso de métodos anticonceptivos,
con el 10 % de las parejas que recurren a la vasectomía
y el 20 % al condón.
¿Por qué el 20 % de las parejas usan el condón como método anticonceptivo,